[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and all hail our grand
leader hail after the big bombshell last
week that it's just all it's just all
one big bloody west world we have a lot
of things to talk about with this one
now in case you're having trouble
getting your head around what's going on
well it turns out rehoboam was right
there rio was right stop this we don't
that's all as predicted mankind had a
complete collapse after 23 years and in
our place rose the machines built to be
like us they now have the same wants and
desires which is why hale created a park
for them that used the humans who were
able to be controlled by the parasites
everyone is now stuck on their own loops
and they're just a means for the host to
have fun huge shout outs to casey
hawthorne on our last video for pointing
out that the olympiad logo is just the
delos one coming full circle showing how
it's all come around to the hosts now
owning a park however some humans have
managed to break free and those that
have can see the tower at the center of
everything and throughout this video
you're going to be hearing a lot of
matrix similarities with the main one
being the concept that humans are slaves
to the machines and that most of us are
trapped in a prison that we can't see
smell or touch those that do awaken are
known as outliers and the freed rebels
end up bursting into the city in order
to save them now in resurrections we
learned that neo had freed humanity but
that he'd been brought back to life and
was now working as a game designer in
season three dolores freed humanity from
rehoboam and she's now been brought back
into the city as a narrative writer for
the hosts which explains why peter
blamed her for the failure of his
marriage and eventual death people are
given loops and these are often just
reused like how they were in the park
this explains why the wing dedicated to
him was decades old and why the newly
assigned peter myers was so angry about
what was to come either way there's lots
of similar scenes to the matrix and i'm
not saying they copied it as these
concepts are as old as movie-making is
it's just the simplest wack and thing to
explain what's happening using a
property that you'll likely already have
a good understanding of honestly i think
this does the matrix sequels better than
the matrix sequels but we'll not get
into that now the entry is titled
xiangxi and it's named after the ancient
chinese philosopher of the same name
which are probably pronounced wrong now
he believed that every person leaves an
impact on the world in some way and even
after death that our essence will be
felt forever due to the things that
we've done he also came up with a
butterfly dream thought analysis that
talked about one of the creatures flying
along one day then a person woke up and
realized that they were dreaming of
being a butterfly but one wouldn't be
able to tell if it was the butterfly
dreaming of being a man or a man
dreaming of being a butterfly loads of
brawl signs i used to talk about in
college and this echoes the sentiments
of william's narration in the opening
and throughout the entry there's a
beauty to this world
an order that's what we like to believe
there's a beauty to this world an order
that's what we like to believe
a grand design
we made sure of that
now the hosts believe that they've
dreamed this perfect world into reality
but was it always like that well we'll
get into it and the point is that
humanity has clearly affected the way
the machines act think and entertain
themselves and though they were meant to
be better they've just turned into us we
join host william who's being
entertained by two humans like how his
predecessor used to find enjoyment in
the park i couldn't shake the feelings
rather this was jason inman who used to
host the dc all access youtube shows but
it's not so no theory time for you
anyway this is all just william delving
into his sick and perverted fantasies to
tie people along mock their beliefs and
also force himself on a woman because of
the power he possesses he's manipulating
both characters here and neither of them
know his name which is hinted at early
on with this line
i'm not sure our friend wants to hear
your war stories i mean you're right
here with us my friend it shows just how
much he revels in using people and
there's also this discussion of two
worlds this is of course very much the
case once more as we have the hosts
running the entire thing whilst the
humans are completely subservient
towards them no more is this scene than
when william goes off and later comes
back to find them unable to start dinner
without him
now he's summoned by clementine who
requests that he deals with a host who's
went rogue and killed a bunch of people
while searching for a game we later
learned this host is called hope and
that she killed a homeless man who's
been popping up throughout the season so
far he was an outlier who became aware
of the tower and thus hail had him taken
out while they're at this conversation
with hope about reality made her go in
search of a deeper meaning to the park
this is something that of course also
mirrored williams journey in season 1
and 2 as he tried to get to the center
of the maze however this was for the
hosts and not for him which could hint
towards how humanity will create an
uprising much like how the hosts did
several of them became self-aware and
they were taken out too showing how
similar that hale is to arnold and ford
she very much oversees the operation and
it's ironic that she was the first host
who was created and she's now ascended
to become a god like they did christina
could very much be seen as the arnold
because she likely doesn't want to keep
perpetuating the madness she's helped to
create and she may even end up winning
hale around just like how ford did
potentially christina might have
subconsciously created the outliers just
like how arnold created the code that
eventually allowed the host to discover
their reality so that they could escape
as we learn christina writes all her
narratives in the park and
subconsciously she may have created ones
that make people become self-aware and
realize what's going on often when
building her narrative that's clearly
based on dolores she talks about her
becoming self-aware and realizing the
world isn't real so this may also be
passed on to the people that end up
becoming outliers william arrives at the
scene and we see an emergency vehicle
that looks exactly the same as the one
that caleb called early on in season
three the humans have been frozen in
place just like the hosts and this is
very similar the massacre carried out by
wyatt
this is hope aren't i two years old
scheduled to transcend next week
now what this transcendence means we
don't fully know but it's likely what
happens during the moment in which the
hosts have the pearls removed from their
heads we know that the sublime was
brought up by william in episode 1 and i
think that the transcendence may involve
moving them from the real world into the
simulation of the afterlife however we
get told that many just want to remain
behind and that they have no interest in
going it confirms that they're just as
happy as the human soldiers stay in the
filth because it enables them to carry
out heinous acts i kinda see this as
being a metaphor for a legend and the
idea that there's an afterlife everyone
could go to heaven right now if it
existed but clearly people on a
subconscious level have a fear that this
is all there is which might be mirrored
in the hosts who would rather just stick
with what they know i hope also carries
a white flower in her hand which we
later see she got from the homeless man
murder is still clearly a big sin here
due to humans not being replaceable and
william is angry that she's decided to
go postal on the park however this also
shows the contradictions as hope was
tasked with killing someone who is above
the park itself but she's told that she
has a lack of respect for life if she
murders those stuck in the prison
william claims to care about life but
he's still a piece of sh and is actually
happy torturing people whilst prolonging
their lives which might be even worse
anyway it's a westworld it's a west
world it's a west world it's a west
world also the credit scene makes more
sense now it's a westworld
next week to christina with the sun
beaming down on her face might be
reaching here but i feel like this is
presented far more in the same vein as
to how dolores was when she woke up in
the first season this is of course to
hammer home the idea that we're now
aware this is a park and it represents
the blissful life that she believes she
leads even though the painting is still
covered in the tower she's completely
ignorant to what's going on because
she's so smitten with teddy how it turns
out that she's got up early to go to
work and finish up some narratives in
episode one her boss complain about her
stories not having enough sex and
violence in them and it actually makes
sense now that we know she's writing
stuff in the park there's also maya's
dreams which might have a darker side to
them last week we heard about the flies
but here we learn that she's had more
her loop always involved her and
christina going to a bar where she'd set
the ladder up on a date the one time
that she put the lipstick on it start
the one with teddy whereas in episode
one nothing here really triggered that
felt all that impactful either way
christina tends to go off without her
and as we know the night time in the
park is where the guests really started
to play up their dark and twisted
fantasies i wouldn't be surprised if
these nightmares that mai keeps having
are things that are actually happening
to her but her brain represses it
because it's too horrifying to confront
christina then walks to work and as we
know the lampposts are mini towers which
explains why they have this shape
there's also this guy awkwardly sitting
on a bench which he likely assumed the
position of because he's just going
through the motions look how rigid he
looks looks like when you've had a curry
and you're trying to force it out
without causing hammer anyway moving on
now this time there's no homeless man
because as we learn hope took him out at
work christina then starts to write a
story that echoes dolores's she's
interrupted by her boss who's similar to
the analyst in the matrix resurrections
is likely probing her to see if she's
become self-aware this conversation also
echoes the one from the first entry it's
a story about a girl i want to write a
new story about a girl
she's a ranger's daughter
a girl who's searching it's this feeling
that you just can't shake the girl
doesn't know what she's searching for
every single day she wakes up
[Music]
the more she sees it
she just knows there's
an emptiness in her life
that there's something wrong with the
world
just before they get to the name of the
person she stops however she is getting
closer to the truth just in the same way
that morpheus rescued neo from the
office christina gets called away by
teddy and he acts as a guide for helping
her see the truth cut across town to
hale who's basically just aboard god
she's smashing up ice sculptures of her
head and we even see she's had a penis
play until his fingers bled was the
summer of 2069 now this is all to make
me so bad now this is all to make people
that she controls dance which is some of
the scene from season one in which
something along those lines happens
eventually she gets him to play a
rendition of perfect day by lou reed
which was used in the trailers song
itself is meant to discuss the perfect
day and what it means to lou in the city
hale created a perfect day paradise
without fault but she's unable to find
conflict and therefore motivation beyond
the mundane she's very bored and after
william arrives she talks about
harmonics and how the tower emits sounds
there was a frequency in which the world
vibrated and caused joy harmony
to blow that frequency
chaos
in chaos the tone resonated in such a
way humans couldn't process their bodies
shut down
their organs stop they thought they were
experiencing god she also goes over the
myths of bored gods and how they descend
to earth at one point she talks about
them turning into swans and not a zeus
who would do this in the legends after
he came down from olympus olympiad is of
course playing on that name and much in
the same way that christina looks over
the characters the gods did too in films
like clash of the titans from the 80s
now this metaphorically of course
highlights the hosts themselves who are
very much gods here that descend in the
park to have their fun william also
brings up that he's made of her code
this is true of all the hosts who we
learn all somewhat reuse elements of
dolores's original design due to her
being the first a hail is frustrated
because the hosts have decided to become
just like the humans instead of
something different what she's really
here for though is to talk about the
outliers and it's at this point that we
see they travel to the tower there's a
weaved entrance made of branches and
this appeared in the sublime when
bernard ended it in episode 3. there's
also a drone host there and as we
discussed when they popped up in that
entry these are off network bodies used
in the most secretive areas originally
they were for restricted parts of the
park but with this tower being hidden
from sight they're now used as guards
along with a security mechs from delos
turns out hope has ended her own life
and william pulls apart the flower which
he still holds they then talk about
hosts refusing to transcend and we get
this awesome line from hale let me just
force us to join you
because that's what they would have done
now they ascend to the top of the tower
and we see that this branch type
structure actually resembles webs more
than anything everyone is stuck in hails
and we of course had flies infecting
people symbolizing how they themselves
became trapped in this web of reaching
they examine the outliers namely the
homeless man and hope who tracked him
down we don't know exactly how he broke
free but we do know that some
manipulation stopped working on him one
day rather than being afraid of his
death he actually found comfort in
having a flower that was real makes me
wonder to what extent the humans
actually have lives and potentially all
their relationships jobs and friendship
groups are chosen by christina who
likely has the power of rehoboth after
she was uploaded into it hope hesitated
before she shot him and this reminded me
a lot of looper namely when the
assassins didn't close their own loops
and instead they listened to their
future selves she clearly saw humanity
in the man and this mirrors how william
spotted it in dolores on his first visit
to the park i also don't know whether
new york is the last habitat on earth
and this could yet again be similar to
the matrix in the fifth film they made
it clear that the world was a mirror of
ours but for the sequels they started
just calling where humanity lived the
city now this seems to be the case here
and other than the rebel outcasts this
appears to be where humanity all resides
now and the sentinels slash drones hunt
down the free mines in the desert we
discover that 38 hosts have ended their
own lives after encountering outliers
and it is possible that caleb might
bring the entire thing down dolores
herself was an outlier too and she led
to the uprising of the hosts so this
would mirror that now in frustration
hail scratches away at her arm which she
allowed the burns to remain on so that
she had a constant reminder deep down i
do think that hales somewhat still cares
for humanity as she adopted charlotte's
family in season 3 before they were
killed i'm surprised she hasn't created
host versions of them as they showed her
another path away from dolores plan
either way she's become aware of another
outlier which he sends william out too
and we also get some iconography that
looks like the maze when the map closes
down and she initiates diagnostics now
across the city the rebels have arrived
in the town on their rescue mission to
pull out the outlier outlier now upon
making it to manhattan everyone is
instructed to take them out and
initially they pause in the street
bringing up iconography of the woman in
the red dress scene from the matrix the
crowd swarms them a lot like the drone
mode and this gives william time to meet
the outlier on the roof now this woman
shares some similarities looks wise to
his wife and also his daughter she talks
about how her husband realized that the
world wasn't real and this could be
symbolic of the original williams need
to constantly venture into the park he
viewed westworld as being the real world
because it allowed people to become
their true selves whereas outside of it
they put on a fake face she talks about
how lonely that her husband must have
been knowing the truth which obviously
is somewhat sympathetic towards
william's perception of the world the
pair share an intimate moment together
and though he goes to shoot her she's
rescued by trini sorry jay i could do a
shot of the statue of liberty which is
ironic due to it symbolizing freedom
over the world that's become a prison
christina meets teddy and he starts to
in towards being the original version
once more last week on the date he
brought up the fact he used to be a
gunslinger with a heart of gold and he
also talked about the train which was
how his loop would begin he says he knew
someone just like her and it makes you
wonder how they're gonna explain his
resurrection now he ended his own life
in season 2 because he realized he
couldn't go any further with dolores
however he's back with his pearl likely
being recovered someone somewhere has
gone and recreated him and it might be
connected to arnold's house which has a
host processing unit his speech about
the world being a lie a story that's
been pulled over christina's eyes
reminded me a lot of morpheuses and he
makes us see how she can manipulate the
world around her again i think she was
selected for this above all the other
hosts because dolores became attached to
rehobem hale likely needed stories
written quickly and to do this all in 23
years would take so much time especially
if there's millions of people in
comparison to westworld this park is
infinitely bigger and she likely needed
a quick way to put things in place it's
the only reason i can think of as to why
she'd run the risk of bringing dolores
back and she meets with her regularly in
order to monitor her as we learned
earlier in the season her boss also
follows her every move and the second
that she breaks out of her loop he
starts calling her up occur to the cafe
scene from the matrix throws never mind
i'll stop doing that i i did watch it
last week to be fair and we get one of
the tensest scenes in the show thus far
a hail is clearly probing her and
there's a lot of similarities here to
their scene in season three the power
roles are reversed though and just in
the same way that christina's boss asked
who the girl's name was in the story
she's desperate to learn who she went on
a date with
and what is this girl's name
what's his name
i don't want to jinx it
really raises the tension but christina
is saved by a plate smash and a guy
getting up and going because she's able
to change and control narratives i
actually think that christina might have
done this as a means to escape but let
me know below exactly what you think a
christina returns to work and after
failing to find charlotte hale as a
character she also searches for dolores
though it says there's no character like
that that was a lie and it immediately
sets off alarm bells looks a bit
suspicious and her boss calls her in and
asks
have you ever questioned the nature of
your reality
this of course calls back to several
other characters asking it in the series
first
have you ever questioned the nature of
your reality
by using her newfound abilities
christina gets him to return home
however he brings a warning to her about
how hale is already suspicious he seems
to genuinely want to help her and he
also brings up the judas steer now this
is something that both teddy and dolores
talked about all the way back in season
1 episode 1. on the westworld subreddit
there's been several theories for years
about who this saying applies to and
there are a couple of different options
and most believe it's dolores as she's
the steer that led the others to
slaughter but she herself doesn't die
she of course caused the host uprising
and in season three we learned she
smuggled out multiple versions of
herself however it could also be the
hell version who's trying to lead the
others into the sublime whilst she
remains alive this is a notable aspect
of season 2 as well as she got host to
traveling in the sublime which made
their bodies crash over the edge of a
cliff so it seemed like they died either
way christina stops this programming and
it's at this moment that i realized
she's very similar to maeve just like
how she could control hosts in the park
christina can control the humans she
very much freezes all mother functions
and writes him a new reality
interestingly they also talk about the
wall garden which in tech is referring
to a closed off network in the next
scene she discovers this by asking to
see the game and it brings up the map
and all the hosts in it it's like
playing the sims it is and christina
come to the realization that she's
written countless narratives we then
occurred to host william bringing up his
narration from the beginning he
unfreezes the real version and the pet
ponder what the duplicate is if he is
catching the virus that makes hosts and
their own lives and the real williams
says it looks like he's reached the
center of the maze he ends by asking
maybe it's time you question the nature
of your own reality possibly hitting the
host william rising up against hale due
to the will that she's created it's also
important to know that he's very much
william's offspring which could be an
under the opening conversation and about
how everyone seems to be ruled by this
thousands of years being ruled by
someone's [ __ ] offspring you wouldn't
call this progress he's just as much a
prisoner as the rest of the hosts and
humans and hail is the one who controls
everything christina too was called a
god by teddy due to her ability to write
stories and it's building towards this
idea that she creates the tales whilst
hail makes sure that they stay locked
into them christina also asks who did
this to her after finally seeing the
tower and teddy says
you did now this could have a number of
reasons that all kind of tie back to the
judas steer potentially dolores caused
all this because she was the one who
caused the uprising in westworld she
also created hail however it could mean
hail hail is a copy of dolores who ended
up defining a new identity and it's
really interesting the way that they're
taking it all in all it was another
great episode that once more shows
westworld is smarter than me as i still
have no
idea what's going on still though i'm
loving it and it's actually kind of
crazy how far left field the show's gone
i kind of right that they actually
skipped over the whole war and just
jumped straight into the aftermath of it
with the host's world also lots of
questions here that will have all the
hosts watching asking are we the baddies
just makes for a great show and i hope
you enjoy this slightly more serious
breakdown now this time i want to hear
your theory time so drop them in the
comments below and let us know extra
points for writing clear time through
time through time before you start now
as a thank you you'll be entered into a
competition where we're giving away
three copies of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now say that to you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers if you want some emails to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of better called soul which
will be linked on screen right now the
latest episode was a banger lots of
spoiler things that i don't want to get
into but yeah go check that out right
after this by the way thanks for
clicking the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time take care peace